Hey, Flix. When you came and you gave me a dinner, are you coming, are you there?
Mommy, please come back. Mommy's here.
Hello? Right.
We've got an agendation today.
Cause I done fucked up.
I need, I needed more time and I might stop my time.
But that's okay, cause look.
I got a cup of safe.
Okay, there we go. Oh, sorry that was really loud for no reason.
Can you hear me? Mommy's here.
I'll be glad to stop you again.
I'll be glad.
As always, please do not listen to this at full volume. I will make mistakes.
Now, you might notice something. You're still naked in the background.
I will deal with you. Okay?
And there's an echo over Flix's head.
Is there actually an echo?
Is there? Is there an echo?
No, I'm, oh, you're debating nasty of us.
I'm already late for monstery and you're debating at a time like this.
I can't hear. Good. Okay.
That's what I did with my knees. Can you see them?
It is a little, a little part.
Oh, and I'm from a secondary one. Ah.
I'm going to...
I'm going to do this.
Make it a nice, what?
Do not put full volume on me, don't you?
Right, so here's the problem.
You're naked. This is the problem.
I've not put clothes on you yet, so I need to do that, like, right now.
Right this very second.
Right, put some clothes on.
So we're going to do that first. I'm just going to check how much you can see.
If I crouch right here.
Okay. And then, if I bring you over,
I put you in the bath because you smelled of plastic.
Okay. Look, this is you.
I'm going to do ASMR on you very shortly, but I just need to set
these things up, okay? Just need to cover up this.
Put some clothes on you.
I'll pop you right there.
That's what you sound like.
I'm going to put some bulk serenade on you.
The problem is, this makes me really, really loud.
Hold on.
I don't want to get a similar.
Don't look in high detail.
Okay, your experience. Not the airway.
Okay, for those of you who don't know, this
is a chiropractor's doll.
Okay?
But it comes anatomically correct for a reefling.
Okay, there's something here that I can't show you.
So I'm going to put paper boxers on you.
So we're going to do this right now.
Just as one would imagine how you do it.
I'm going to start with the front.
Oh no, my square.
Yes, I'm covering up your no-no square.
Okay, this is a bit too big.
I'm going to fold it in half.
I'm changing your diaper.
Oh no, I can't.
I saw it. You better not have.
So what I'm going to do
is, see like you're even holding it.
Oh my God, welcome to the massage parlour sir. It's $5 for the special end.
Really, it's more than I fucking know what I'm going to be doing next morning.
I mean it really is. So we're going to put tape around the front part
and then we're going to do the back as well. Okay, you'll have the end done.
I'll dab you right out on your...
So we're just taking a little bit of tape.
Also, I apologise if I sound really tired.
I took sleep medication but only slept 5 hours so it's still in my system.
Alright, don't look at your cheeks. Your cheeks are very
well-cheeked up. So we're just going to tape this part.
Okay, maybe you're allowed to see your cheeks a little bit.
We are packing, you are. I need to cover you up.
You're double-cheeked up on a Thursday afternoon.
I remember just something. Yes, unfortunately I was a bit busy
dealing with some things but a fantastic news for the reeflings.
I've been very selfish
and the third
edder is being a batch for me.
Which is YouTube content.
Okay, so know that you're looking a bit more presentable.
Hi.
Very presentable.
I'm now going to cover up your butt.
Because y'all have booties and maxims. This is too glues maxims.
See, this is what I'm supposed to do
before the ASMR stream started. Now I'm just pretending it's ASMR.
I'm just talking to you regularly levels across the room.
I felt that sping.
The point of this ASMR stream is some people get this
I forget the word. It will come to me later. But some people
get this thing where if I touch the doll, you'll feel it. Like where I'm
touching the doll. I'm going to muck about with that. I'm going to put my fake nails on as well
Don't worry, I'm going to put real nails on. Not my...
I still have the manicure sitting on my nails.
You feel that sympathetic reaction.
Something like that. He has a hole.
Oh my god, you can see that? Oh shit, you saw.
Look, I had to get him atomic.
For what? For my needs and the reeflings needs.
I didn't know you could even fucking see that detail on the webcam.
What else can you see on the webcam?
The beach of her nails for you ASMR.
Very accurate.
It has only taken 5 minutes and 18 seconds for you to turn it into ASMR.
I'm just absolutely pathetic at ASMR.
Live ASMR is just an absolute
atrocious thing for me because I just get to yapping on another shot.
Actually, I'm going to put your box of nails on.
Actually, I'm going to do something controversial.
ASMR to yapping stream speed drawn
80%. Thank you.
I'm going to cover up your derriere like so.
This is what I should have been doing but instead I made a cup of tea.
I'll wake up shortly. Don't worry, I'm going to wake up shortly.
It just takes me a moment to...
Oh, there you go. My god, now you're really getting covered up.
Give us a G string.
Cup of tea sounds like a great idea if you want to be me and the fellow brush.
Speaking of brush, I might have a brush call up coming up.
Well, one pulls cup. But I think she's going to bring it.
I've got some prettyish kind of ones with an English go.
I wanted them with an honorary stop.
And the other one's called a string.
Right, we've done that mission of getting me shut up.
I'm going to put the paper away next.
Because what I'm going to do...
Oh thank god, oh my god, I thought you could see my...
my stuff from last night.
Before I went to sleep. Oh god, my knees are sore.
They're all red.
Can we get a hat? Oh my god, I forgot about your... I need to do your hat. Hold on.
I need to do your...
your addiction to me.
Your nicotine patch.
Sorry, that was really loud. Like, it's not ASMR.
I don't know why we're pretending anymore. It's not real ASMR.
I'm going to do your nicotine patch.
Hey, what the fuck is in my tea? No, there's something in my tea.
Can you see that?
Did I use my fingers to get it out like a weirdo?
I don't have a spoon.
Do you see the wee thing? That bit? That's something that's not supposed to be there.
I think it's a fiber of... it's a little fly. No, it's a fiber of my cloth.
How am I going to make an amal to be?
Amal to use my fingers or do I need to go get a freaking... what is it? It's just a bit of fiber of cloth.
It's like my hoodie, like for example.
Sorry. Yeah, use fingers, alright.
That's what I missed.
Did I get it? You're going to drink the tea off my fingers?
Thank god I didn't have my fake fingers on for that, are you joking?
Oh my god, the tea's warm. It's delicious.
I wish everyone a very Merry Christmas.
Okay, I'm going to put your nicotine patch. You have a patch on the right side of your...
like if I'm looking at you, it's on the right side.
That's where your nicotine patch sits.
And it is in a square shape.
Kind of. Well, it is a square shape, not kind of.
I'm just guessing shapes up here.
So that's it there.
I just have to over...
Sorry, I keep forgetting where the camera's pointing.
I need to make myself smaller, maybe.
But this one just goes right here. But first thing we're going to do...
we're going to color it the correct color because it's got
like a tan kind of band-aid
tinge to it. And then that's you.
This is how we keep up with each other.
Through a nicotine patch.
Which I already need as of late.
Oh, it's a marker. Yeah.
These kind of markers are for the skin. I can write on myself if you want.
If you want to write me, I'll write something on myself.
So I'm just going to stick here.
I don't want to drop too much.
Stick your little nicotine patch on your head.
And then it's official you.
So you just want to catch a little bit.
You don't need to catch the whole thing.
Just stick on your head. Oh look, it's a leaflet.
There you are. Do you want me to draw on your boxers or anything?
Oh god, are you tinting through the piece of paper?
Naughty refling. Don't tint through the piece of paper.
But now this is a lower-accurate refling.
I like to do all the ASMRs.
So next I'm going to put my fake nails on.
Because these nails, these ain't going to cut it for the ASMR that I want to do with you.
So I'm literally just grabbing
my mini nails.
I actually haven't read the instructions so we're going to go...
Oh no, that's for my shock collar. Don't need the instructions for that.
Come here.
Oh it's cell type. Everyone's going to know that I inked myself.
Right, so we're going to be wearing these.
These are Lego.
Oh sorry, that was so loud right next to the microphone.
Sit on him. Your wish was my fucking command, did you Jones?
Alright, let me just put you there refling. Okay, let me just go do something.
Now that I have done my task, I need to see...
Oh sorry, refling.
Sit on your own, you're okay baby.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean to do that.
You're okay darling.
Okay, let me see if we're going to figure out how to put these on.
So these are fake nails and you just stick them on
via this glue.
So, wish me luck. Okay, sorry, I'm going to do it behind my screen.
You're winning. God, I wish I was that lucky.
Yeah, I literally bought a little ball so I could roll play with you. No, that doesn't make me weird.
I love it here.
Okay, I'm going to finish my teeth because look, it's getting smaller.
I'm learning about
my teeth. Now you can blend in at this sleepover.
You're like, why did I get invited to this?
Okay, I finished my teeth.
I was never finished my teeth in town.
I'm opening the package.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh my god, alcohol. Oh my god, you didn't tell me
that you drank alcohol, Mifun.
Oh, you feel everything.
What are the alcohol wipes for?
What's this for? Oh my god, I have a spear.
Mifun, you better listen
to all of my instructions or else.
Why does it give me a spear? It must be to pick off the nail.
It must be. I do not believe.
Okay. Oh my god. Oh my god, we're such girls together.
Oh my god, we're real girls.
It's to shank your enemies with. Pretty shy coming out.
Oh my god, we're such girls.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do with this. I'm just here for the fun time.
Okay, right, so nail blowing.
For external use only, avoid contact with eyes.
In the unlikely event of irritation, please discontinue use.
Ingredients, ethanol 2, cyanol, alcohol 8,
polyethylene, like polymethyl, meth.
Oh my god, why is there meth in my nail glue?
What next, man? Is the alcohol for the baby to take care of?
What, to prepare? Oh, to prepare the surface?
Why no? Oh my god, 75% alcohol.
I'm getting steam in tonight, Lance.
Jesse, we need to cook. What's inside? Oh my god, I've just finished my
KFC, by the way. A little lemon.
Oh. Fuck it stinks.
Okay, if this means I'm preparing all right.
That's right, that's right. Time to get drunk.
Keep drinking, Nathan. Keep drinking.
Good boy, just keep drinking. You can crash at my place tonight, good boy.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Hahaha.
Oh, you saw it, you saw it, Maryse was the yander.
You're coming back home with me.
Oh, where did it go? Okay, great, I've put alcohol everywhere.
I'll try. And now, we're going to watch...
Can I sit on you while I do this? Or can you just go there for now?
We need to be super careful when we do this, because this
will stick these on very harshly, okay?
Oh, piss, who do you...
Oh, shit, sorry.
Hello?
Are you coming in? Are you scared?
Oh, sorry, it's one of them open mechanics.
Sorry, they never, wait.
Is this not one of those lids that open itself?
I can't, I can't find the tip. The tip is sealed over.
No, please.
This is gonna, how did I get in?
Do I cut your tip, yes or no?
Answer me right now, do I cut the tip? Spin it.
The, the glue? What do you mean, spin it?
Spin this?
I don't know what you mean by spin it.
Don't cut it. I want me to cover it.
I can't spear the tip, there's nothing to spear.
Your tip is so, like, tiny.
Sorry, I know my tracking keeps getting lost
every two seconds, it's because I need to look up.
Okay.
Surely this is what I needed to do.
I label it, thank you for coming on me.
See, told you it's not pre-recorded. It's an average size tip. I don't know if that worked.
Oh my god, that's it.
It's getting trolled, sorry. Circumcision ASMR.
Oh, should I saw?
That worked.
Okay, okay, everyone stay calm.
Cam, everyone stay calm. This is gonna work.
I just, okay, okay, so that's the thumb.
Oh, shit. I wasn't prepared, I wasn't ready.
Okay, so you literally put a dab of gold, of gold, of glue.
And then you place down the fake nail.
And then you just hold it.
Okay, that's what I wanted to do.
No more interest to spear, that's what I wanted to do. And then you just gotta
push, push, push, push, push. Gold where?
No, push, push, push, push, push.
Oh, is it even sticking?
What?
Okay, if it doesn't stick the first time, just add a wee bit more.
Did I, would the alcohol nullify the glue?
No, I'm just being dumb, sure.
Again, push, push, push, push, push.
I'm using the clear.
Okay, okay, again some.
It's not, well,
hmm.
Hold on, this is definitely user error.
Because this place had far too many good reviews.
They really used their error. They had far too many good reviews.
For my dumb ass.
Oh, I don't want to jinx it.
It doesn't want to look like me.
Anywho.
Right.
Okay, I think I'm doing it. And then try on your toes.
I ain't got no toes, chief.
My toes went to France. They died in a fire.
A great fire of London Bridge.
Okay, we're literally just doing the exact same thing. We're caking it in glue.
We're attaching it.
Uh-huh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, don't talk to me unless you're this big.
Okay.
Oh my god, look, my personality is changing in 4K because I stuck some nails on.
Slee, honestly though.
This nail set is a sleigh. It's Mermaid inspired. That's why I picked it.
Oh my god, I'm such a...
Oh my god, look. Watch this sleigh.
Oh my god.
I guess I'm out.
Mommy has become a queen. Alex Gray. Yeah, you like that?
Are you ready for me to touch you with your nails?
Yeah.
I know this may come as a surprise to some of you, but
I'm not much of a girl and girl.
I said it. I said the truth. I'm not much of a girl and girl.
So when I do something like this, I feel very feminine.
All men are men. Cinnamon. Raw cinnamon.
All men are friends.
Oh shit, I fucked up the placement on the index finger.
I'm more of a mean lord than I care what I look like.
Did I say thank you, Elbot, for the membership?
Oh, but it did. I'm a little bit distracted right now.
Anyway, so this is everything that...
Oh my god, I just broke a nail.
Am I covered in... can I touch this or not?
I did broke a nail. I can't believe it.
Oh my god, I'm gonna make it.
Is that what spear is for? It must be to take off the nail.
Right, we're adding more glue. Okay, let's retry that again.
Rip now. God, this is taking forever.
Bro, the stream hasn't even started. It's been 25 minutes now.
Okay, I'm just glad you guys like spending time with me because I'm so bad at this.
This is terrible.
Take that, you old shit. Oh, Mercy hasn't... no.
A.C. has a new short out if you haven't seen it.
I also tagged Azura's short because I didn't know she even did that kind of stuff on stream.
So if you're bored waiting for me to stick nails on myself, you can literally just watch Azura's
little short right now. Okay, same thing though.
We'll put a little bit glue. And then we stick her on.
And then I think I've completed the first set of my nails.
Oh my god. Are you ready?
You're broken now. You're just like one of the girls.
Oh my god. Tell me you do not want me to give you
head pads right now. Imagine my nails going through your scalp.
They're actually so cute.
I'm such a girl though.
I'm actually such a female. I'm such an XX.
Oh shit, you can't see them. Right, let's do that again. Let's go again.
Okay, this is even harder because this hand is covered in nails and this hand isn't.
This is harder than one made to see.
Oh Jesus. God, these nails are long. I bought a short on purpose.
On purpose. Sorry, the color is purple so my brain said purple.
Are you coming? Oh my god, please tell me this hasn't closed up already.
Oh, there you go. See it? Oh sorry, I keep...
It's all wet. It's all wet.
And then I'm going to have to put the glue down. Oh my god.
I can't do both things at once. Okay, I'm going to stick my nail on.
Spread the glue around a little bit. I do have C-shaped nails
which are... what do you mean?
Message deleted by Vealer Moderator? Wait, is that real?
Did you mean that?
Did you mean to ban the Super Chat?
I look up and the message is gone.
No KFC, stream until the nails come off.
Oh my god.
Thank you the Vealer Moderator. Do a Valley Girl accent.
Sorry, I don't know why Valley Girl in my head just means
equals mourning. Message included.
Get blasted out of this one. Have you played Disco Silent?
I don't know. I don't know what it is. What, is it related to nails?
Oh my god, the Elden Ring Spiders.
The fucking creepy enemies in Elden Ring.
Terrifying.
Sorry, I picked glue on them.
Sorry, my voice is going already. It appears I have not
rested enough. But that's okay. I'm just happy to be here.
Tell us, I've blinged on our sling, Jesus.
Do you mean I've blinged on the refunds?
Okay, dude. Put some glue on the thing.
Can you shoot magic though?
Just squirt and count? I'm fucking with you. I'm so sorry.
Please don't listen to me. I am not well rested.
I have no filler. Can I have your nails?
You can buy them on Nailsuses if you want them.
Or do you mean you want my used leftover
nails? That's different.
I did not put enough glue on this.
I'm crying, throwing up. There wasn't enough glue.
God, this is actually a lot harder than a...
Ooh, sugar. Space and everything. Nice. That's far too much.
That nail's not coming off for centuries. Hold on.
Oh my god, I've just noticed
my inking. Oh for fuck's sake.
I've actually just noticed my inking thing is literally on my desk
right now. I'm so sorry.
I hope that doesn't look too short.
Take some of that off. It is? I forgot to put it away.
Holy... I don't even want it here.
Okay, there we go. Put that one on.
It is much better. Can we see it?
Absolutely not. It is illegal.
Oh my god, I'm such a girl.
You know I'm a real girl when I put love hearts on myself.
Oh yeah, you hear that ASMR?
Oh yeah, you're like...
I'm such a female.
Okay, three more to go.
Oh yeah.
That was a hard one.
Could you imagine if I was like that?
Did you see that? That was fine.
You got the nails to work.
I'm such a special girl.
More like special dudes.
Okay, middle finger.
I'm a Barbie girl.
And I'm a Barbie man. Wrapping plastic.
That's fantastic. You can brush my hair.
And trace me everywhere.
Imagination. Life is your creation.
Come on, pop it. Let's go party.
I'm a ginger and green girl. And I'm a fan.
It's not even a real country actually.
Sorry, you've been fooled. Scotland isn't a real country. It's actually just a tourist trap of England.
I'm sorry that you fell for it.
I'm sorry you had to find it this way as well. Actually, Scotland isn't real.
Oh for fuck's sake, I can't get it. Oh my god, it won't come off.
They've got like a sticky tag to keep them down.
Oh, I already knew that one.
Scotland is actually real as a hyal.
It's not ginger. It's one.
Ask the sauce. Amy, I love you. I love you the whole face.
Amy, why did you think you were wearing it to ginger? Please, allow me.
And for anyone else that's like, Amy's not ginger. Amy wasn't ginger until she changed her model color.
She's clearly, mmm, well known as orange.
Okay, orange is ginger.
Orange is ginger.
Orange. Sorry, that was really low praise.
Last one.
Sorry, I just need to get the figurine out of the way because the last thing I want is any accidents.
Oh, my nail just came off.
Okay, my nail just went flying off. Reflowness is all your fault.
This is all your fault.
Okay, let's try it again.
Okay, we have two nails.
We need to go again.
That was a wild and inappropriate ASMR award poster.
Oh, that stopped. Do you remember when those
awards happened? And the people that were selected
didn't even make ASMR roleplays. I remember
learning about that and I was like, damn,
you almost look in trouble. Does Amy mean
ginger have anything to do with the self-piped meme about ginger? Oh, no, no.
It's nothing to do with that. Amy was created
in my image. I knew I wanted a emot or
because it's my number one.
So she was made in my image. They were all made in my image.
Some things that interest me. She views
a slight exception because she was crafted in someone else's image. However,
I did actually. I had the final say on everyone so
if you've got a problem
with any of the girl's designs,
shove up your arse because I love them all.
You should have done this with the design.
No. No, I shouldn't have.
Okay, can you hear that squeaking?
That's my thumb.
There's like air moving trapped.
Okay, I think I may have done it.
Hold on. Shhh.
Okay, real ASMR.
Shhh.
Oh my god, real ASMR.
And it only took me
30 minutes to get here.
Ripped fondle.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
Can tap on the remote all power.
Shhh.
I want to put you there.
Oh, Riflin, what happened?
Riflin, that wasn't very say so of you.
What's going on here? Is that because I sat on you?
Riflin, is that because I sat on you?
What happened?
Danny, you put another piece of paper on you.
I need to.
He got me shoved up. Fucking clearly.
Oh my god, your winky's are worse.
Hold on, let me get a piece of paper.
I guess I'm not done setting up your outfit yet.
Sorry, I really like it.
Oh fuck.
I think a bit of glue got stuck to the scissors.
Something tells me a bit of glue sucks.
I want to put a lid on the fucking glue.
This is so dangerous.
You're going in the bag of shame. How do you?
It's a completely natural reaction.
Okay, I won't shame you for that.
We're just going to give you a little bit more padding.
If that's okay with you.
If I cut, there's definitely glue on the scissors.
Where's the cell tape?
Can I get cell tape with these nails on?
Where the fuck is my nail?
Where's my nail?
When did that come off?
Hello?
Where's my nail?
Are you joking?
Hello?
I've lost my nail. It's gone to France.
It's just gone. I ate it.
How did I miss something that's that big?
You can see the glue that's sitting on it.
I've got your nail. I wouldn't even dirt it.
Well, I mean, at least I can get the cell tape super easily now.
You ain't the nail client. Target the client.
Turn around and let us check.
Turn around and lift the camera.
Okay.
As you can see, the cell tape is ruined.
The cell tape.
The cell tape is gone.
Oh, I'm sure it'll show up somewhere.
Okay, Reefland, time to give you some modesty back.
Because this is a bit outrageous behaviour.
You can't even be cutting about like this on a live stream. Do you understand?
Okay, good Reefland, good boy.
Wait, sorry. Yeah, very good boy.
Should I make my V-tuber smaller?
Now you have those two nails for this V-tuber thing?
Oh, that's like real Andrew.
I can make myself smaller if I'm kind of getting on the way too much of that action shot.
You lost it when putting it in the plastic bag.
What? No way!
Reefland, you're so right. We found it. Thank you, Reefland.
What the fuck? Crowned that mannequin right now.
How on earth did you fucking catch that?
It's literally in the bag.
Nice catch. Oh, I pulled it.
Don't you hate from the hook?
Should I pick that off? Sorry.
Sorry, sorry if you saw my face. Oh my god, I look like an average person.
Oh my god. Right, for the billions of time I'm putting
so much glue, there's no way that this can
viably come off, okay?
Oh god, I can smell that. And then we'll dry it a little bit.
And that means...
Okay, there. I have a full set of nails on.
Sonny's not an animal? I can't believe that.
That was so well spotted. Honestly, I can't believe we did that.
It definitely cannot come off.
Okay, it only took us 41 minutes
but I'm ready for the ASMR, okay? And I hope you
are equally ready for the ASMR. What I'm going to do is I'm going to make my VTuber model
a wee bit smaller. Not like
insane smaller but just a little bit off to the side, you know?
I'm not actually bringing the camera over here.
Sorry, let me re-calibrate real quick, okay?
Oh my god, I can't fucking touch it. How the fuck the girls wear nails?
Like,
in the most respectful way, I've got video games to play.
I've got vermin tight to fuck around on, okay?
I don't know how you girls are doing it, right? How is the best angle?
You would have thought I would have figured out a better angle but I didn't. Okay.
So, mine's too weak.
One. I'm just going to start my face, okay?
Wait, hold on. One minute.
The microphone behind the webcam.
This is a bit better directionally as I put you on the crinkliest
packets possible.
Excuse me. I'm just moving something around
for you, baby. Okay, there you go.
Are you ready for your massage? Good. If you slate me a fiver, you'll get a happy end.
That's how it works around these parts.
Okay.
I can just
touch your forehead.
I don't know if it's loud enough. Maybe I need to put the
webcam on my legs. Sorry. The webcam.
No.
If I'm bringing you up, are you going to see the stuff in the background?
Just a little bit. Don't look in the background.
I'm plenty happy. Thank you, boy.
Pay up. Thank you.
Just so you can see both things.
Do you take payments in internal organs? I could be, isn't it?
Can you kid me?
If you're a bird sleeping outside the window, that's because there's a bird sleeping outside the window.
Okay.
I can probably pick it up.
I'm walking up again.
Thank you, daughter.
Shh.
Maybe start with your hands, actually.
Give your fingers a little squeeze.
Hmm?
Did you... I don't know if you... for anyone
a bird of your... because round and round the garden
like a teddy bear, one step, two
step all the way there and you get a little tickle, tickle.
On your armpit, tickle, tickle, tickle.
That could take my finger.
And trace up your arm.
That's your radius and ulna.
These bones are actually quite interesting
because they twist perfectly.
So if you think of your bone structure in your forearm, the radius and ulna,
they twist very easily with the tomato wrist.
That's really interesting. I like it.
You got your radius and ulna here
and your wrist.
And the wrist has the most
intricate bones in the body and your feet.
That's like the second most intricate
for the amount of little bones you've got. But the wrists, because the wrists are so
versatile, they need to be able to
do a lot, especially if you consider our evolution.
They need to be able to...
You can see the silence behind it, actually.
You can see all these tendons, these bones, these veins.
That's all very intricate.
I'm going to go up past your radius and ulna. And we hit your
biceps and your triceps.
Back here. Please ignore Gimli running around the house.
If you heard that.
Then you come up to your shoulder.
It's called the clavicle.
The collar bone.
The collar bone that goes here.
Then the area between your neck and your collar bone.
It's called decliatage.
And it's straight up stone from French.
It's a decliatage area.
Do you want to see how I take this?
And your pectoral muscles on your chest.
Is it your pectoral muscles?
But you might often hear them refer to as pecs.
If you see male body builders,
they might be quite pronounced.
Sorry, I messed up a little bit.
They might be quite pronounced.
That's perfectly natural. It's just biology.
Especially in female body builders, you can actually see the definition of the pectoral muscles
versus the chest fat, if you will.
Then we go down to your rib cage.
If you want to think of your abdomen,
your rib cage comes two thirds down to here.
Rib cage.
You can actually feel where your rib cage ends.
If you set up, you can feel it right now against you.
You can feel exactly where your rib cage ends.
Around this part.
Some people can be born with a lower rib cage or a wider rib cage.
That's okay. It's perfectly natural.
Not everyone's going to come out like a textbook mannequin.
Then as we go further down your stomach.
You've got your tummy area, your digestive tract.
We also have your hip bones.
Because you are a man,
you have a V shape that naturally forms in this area.
It comes a harsh V.
That happens at puberty, believe it or not.
This V shape should form.
As for your hips.
Your hips should not store too much fat.
Normally what happens when a male stores fat
is it will go to his stomach first.
Believe it or not, you're gluteus maximus.
Have you ever heard of women
being annoyed that men have a nicer
rump naturally?
Because when women store fat, the reason behind that is for pregnancy
to make sure there's resources for the child.
But men, since they can get impregnable.
You put it in your badonkadonk and you put it in your lovely tummy
and then it will equally distribute through your body.
Where's women?
It will unequally distribute.
Which is quite normal, please don't be embarrassed if you have cellulite.
But for women, normally the storage
especially in a pouch.
I just called it a pouch these days.
I'd show you mine but I'm not wearing anything.
Which will stick out a little bit.
Some women have their womb sticks out.
Believe it or not, you can have a womb that sticks out, not just the stomach fat.
That's quite interesting on the back.
As you go past down your hips, you come to the femur.
The bone that's in your thighs
is called the femur.
Do you want to know what happens in the femur?
That lovely magic happens in the femur.
Your blood is produced.
The femur is very efficient at restocking your blood supply.
Do you want the bad news?
If you break your femur, you are in danger.
So let's not be breaking femurs.
Let's not be becoming a statistic.
As long as I can have you.
Thank you at the end of the day.
Yes, you can absolutely bleed out if you break your femur.
So let's not be breaking femurs.
If you get drunk on a night out and your friends are there, you need to jump off the high high.
You got no, sorry.
Femur hardly even know where.
And then you go past your thighs.
And you go kneecaps.
So when you are born, my little leaflin,
when you came straight out of my womb, because obviously I birthed you and I was pregnant by you,
your kneecaps had not fused yet.
You were born with the
different bones that you need for your kneecaps.
But they do not fuse until the six month mark
through ossification.
The ossification is the terminology for when bones are done.
Your little kneecaps came in at six months.
Lord of Storms, thank you.
So whenever you see mothers like, oh my child didn't start
doing this at this milestone or whatever.
Sometimes everyone's different.
Some babies can completely skip the crawling stage.
They can just walk in overnight.
And if you go past your knees,
we have your lovely calf muscles, which
now this is where we talk about blood flow.
So capillaries from your heart.
So their heart will pump through arteries, oxygenated blood.
So pump, all through your body.
And it's got quite a distance to go when it gets down to your legs.
Big distance, okay?
So pump through your arteries and then oxygenates
all the muscles and everything that needs oxygen.
But how do we prevent the
oxygenated blood while it travels back to your heart through blood fresher?
How do we stop it from accidentally going backwards?
Well there's this thing called back flow valves,
okay? So think of a tube.
And then it only allows a one way because there's actually a hidden mechanic.
So every time your heart pumps, it opens up and pushes the blood
and it goes pew, pew, pew.
And because it closes,
that prevents any back flow of deoxygenated blood.
Because if your arteries started going backwards
and your veins started going backwards, we're in trouble.
Your body works its hardest to keep you in check
and keep you nice and healthy.
And the easiest way to engage this,
to help pump the blood back to the heart up here,
is engaging your muscles. So you don't want to tell you, oh, get up.
There's a very easy way that you can actually
engage your calf muscles. I can show you if you want.
These are your calf muscles.
Because this is the furthest away from your heart,
you need to take good care of your legies. That's why walking is so bad.
And taking the calf.
Are you a nursing student? Nope, I'm uneducated.
I just like looking at YouTube videos about biology.
I can show you. So this is how you
do your calf muscles, okay? Are you ready?
Literally, this looks so simple
on paper, but this is so good for your calf muscles. Just
stand with your feet together, and then go up when you tip your toes,
and then, and up, and then, and up, and then, and up, and then, and up, and then,
and up, and then. Really good for your blood flow.
Really, really good for your blood flow. That's it. That's what you have to do.
And then that's,
whenever I say, oh, great, get up, brief ones, everyone get up.
I'm gonna go get a break. That's what you should be doing.
That's your calf muscles down here.
Is it tibia and fibia down here? Or am I making that up?
Radius and ulna. Tibia and fibia?
Hmm, not sure I'm getting that one.
And then your feet. Very intricate. So
if you like to consume alcohol, you know what to do. You know what to do. Refling.
Don't consume too much, because alcohol is poison.
I'm not gonna tell you how to live your life. Okay?
That's how your feet, you can get this condition
called gout, believe it or not, and gout.
Gout just is a disorder
caused by alcohol, which makes your feet incredibly painful.
Incredibly, incredibly painful.
And if you go to the doctor about it, they prescribe you painkillers,
and they'll give you a little leaflet that says,
stop drinking as much alcohol.
But you're allowed to, you can have a magic brew, a magic potion every once so often,
but don't do it to harm yourself, do it to have good time.
Yep, I've broken those bones. It's tibia and fibia.
Oh, I remember. I thought it was a disease
for pirates. Oh no, no, gout is if you have alcohol
at the same time. I think if it also have a red meat diet,
you should be careful if you have too much red meat. She says,
gout is actually the name of the song Shadows of the Moon.
That's scurvy. Yeah, scurvy is when you don't eat fruit and veg.
But your toes, got five cute little toes.
There's, you won't believe this.
But polydactyl people are among us, okay?
No, I'm not polydactyl. Polydactyl means you were born
with extra fingies and toes, okay?
It's actually a lot more common than you think. You would never know.
Unless someone confessed it to you. But normally if it's on the hands,
it gets removed. Well, I've got green on my fingers from the love heart.
Oops, sorry if you see green. I'm turning into Shrek.
But yes, if someone is born with polydactyl
on their hands, normally it's like an extra pinky here. And they get surgically
removed. But if it's polydactyl, is that a painting of Isaac reference?
Real answer. And then,
little toesies. If it happens
on the feet, most parents actually don't bother.
They're removing it. I'm getting used to removing it if it's on your toes either.
I have two nails on one of my toes. What does that make me?
Not polydactyl. Polydactyl is definitely when there's an extra
ligament or something. If it's an extra nail, I think that's just a
misinput. It's a misinput.
It evens most of your body.
Polydactyl is a
polyamorous pair of dactyl.
Yeah, that's your body reference.
Now, as for male attribute things
about the body, other than this line,
I'm not sure what a good thing is. Oh, I've not done your head, have I?
Silly me, I forgot. So we went up to your
your decliatage.
Touching on your neck and showing your ears. You must protect
your ears, okay? Especially if you're a concert goer
must put in earphones or else I'm going to be upset.
You need to put in little earplugs to protect you from music because it's far too
wind. Far, far too much.
I'm gonna go and give you a little head scratch.
Have you ever? Well, this is my
theory about ASMR, by the way. I really enjoy ASMR.
I thoroughly enjoy ASMR. I think
ASMR is related
both to our evolutionary instincts
for bonding and also what we were raised
like, okay? So, now, if you think,
wait, wait, wait, wait, back then. Now, don't laugh, don't laugh, because I'm saying monkeys, but
you know how monkeys grew each other? Well, this shows companionship,
this shows admiration, love, it strengthens bonds
and monkeys are more likely to share food among each other,
among us. And I
think that trait of companionship and of
altruism has persisted through the
missing link and we've ended up with it as well.
And that is why it feels so so nice and someone
please if you're here, for example.
And I think it's natural that we humans
also have this missing trait
and that's what makes it so good and
succinctly to get that kind of one-on-one
attention. And
they also do it to groom the bugs that are
over here, but thankfully we no longer have to do that.
And
but yes, it helps to socialize
and all that. And I think ASMR is a good outlet
or I'm biased towards ASMR, I think it's a good tip for
what you need, because sometimes you just need a little bit
of encouragement, a bit of reassurance, because
you know, we're all just doing life at the same time for the
first time. Like this is the first time we've played this video game, not gonna lie.
Sometimes it's hard mode. Sometimes you
thought the game would be easier and it's still on hard mode
and if you get 20 minutes of pee
then yeah.
That's my theory about ASMR. It's kind of left
over and also like if your
mum touched you into bed, for example, played with your
hair and
that kind of thing could translate, because some people don't get tingles at all, but some
people are like so success, but like I could touch your cheeks right now
I mean.
There's some people like really
fast ASMR.
Yeah, for those of you
who can feel
that transfer ting
I'm worried that the need for positive affirmations
can lead to narcissism. No, I don't think so.
I get the pain too, you're getting too human, but
from not to sound arrogant, but from what I make
I try and make the positive affirmations. You know the hips being touched
a little bit. You are gonna hear the paper
I'll probably see if I can get the image right.
This is nothing to do with what you're saying, but I'm going
failing for the first time. I've got to show up with a boat and less than an hour.
Do you need to pack a sandwich and stuff? Make sure you put deodorant
on and have lots of fun sailing and be super safe.
Wear a life jacket and don't panic.
Panic is what leads to death. Not that you're gonna die. Have fun
last rabbit, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, I didn't know what to say.
Don't flip.
It's okay if you're busy, you don't have to stay.
You've got to get stuff done.
Don't just tap on the video.
I think if you're a narcissist
it probably would have developed. I don't
think anime girl on internet would make it develop.
You think I'd make a great mother?
Well, the reflins call me mome. I'd like to think I'm their mome
if that's not weird of me.
I love my little reflins.
I give them all the attention
when you get home after work.
I give you shoulders a little massage to try and de-stress you.
And then you'd be like, what's for dinner, Stroni?
And I'll be like chicken again, because I like chicken a lot.
I give you those shoulders a little massage.
I squeeze down on your thighs.
No, don't try steps. These are traps. These are called traps.
I can't remember the full name of the muscle trap.
Trapezoids?
That sounds like a square.
I think of you as mome-wave.
Mome-wave. Do you want dinner or a bath?
Or maybe me.
Oh, I said the reflin. Do you want dinner?
A bath?
Or me?
I'd put you in the bath and I'd scrub you there
and get you all clean. I feed you.
And then this part. The voodoo doll is kicking it.
I go for some fish.
The voodoo.
Okay, so you get home. And obviously I greet you at the door.
And I go read one.
But you're all dirty and tired from work.
Oh wait, no. You need to go for your post-work poopy. Go to the toilet.
Go to the toilet for 30 minutes after work.
And then you have a bath on your phone. I know how it works.
And while you go poopy, I will fill up a nice warm bath for you.
And I'll put bubble bath in it. Because, okay, this is a girl.
This is a girl only fact, if you didn't know.
Lush came out with Minecraft themed
bath bombs and stuff. So I'll get you a Minecraft themed bath bombs.
And
are these two separate baths? Yeah.
I would not run a bath while you were taking a shit in the same room.
I'm not going to be inhaling those fumes, okay? Thank you for the offer.
Let me inhale those fumes to check your digestive tract.
That was a really kind offer though. Thank you.
That was too kind. Please don't ever cook again.
And then when you get out of your post-work poopy
put you in the bath and then
wash down your back for you and put you in the back.
And get a wee cloth and I'll wash down all the bits that are really hard to wash.
So I'll start washing your neck
and then I'll go over your shoulders with just some soap and a cloth.
Scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub.
And then you tell me about your day
and you see work was the same as always.
And I say, damn, that sucks.
But I'm just listening
to you because it's good to listen to you.
And I ask how you feel when you tell me your time and I know it's okay.
And then the water, you hear the water trickling down.
It trickles down your back. When I get the cloth and I ring it out
it goes
scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub.
There you go.
And then I do a little bit down the back of your arms as well
because it's not the only way.
Scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub.
Then your arms.
They're just over there. I need to go grab them. They're like right over there.
Scrub down here.
And then when you finish in the bath,
actually no, I'll let you cook in the bath and then I'll go finish it in.
Then when you're ready, you get a nice home hearty meal
and obviously it's going to be chicken and carrots and
potato because it's my favorite. I like that kind of stuff.
Stewie, kingdom meals, or like mashed potato and chicken
and like carrot. I just really like carrot
and mashed potato and chicken.
It's my dream to eat it every single night.
But I can't because I have an iron deficiency.
Can I be the dinner? No, no, you have to eat first.
I need to fill your tummy because that, oops, sorry, my cheer disc.
I need to fill your tongue tongue. And then it gets
big and round because you're digested. And then I touch over
your tummy. And then that's what the floor plays for me.
Can I get some cult urine from inside?
I'm the dessert. Okay. And then once
you're all full,
I'll get you to lay down in the bed so I can start an ASMR session on you.
I'm going to pop you down. And then when I put you down in the bed
for the ASMR session, look at you go.
And then I go read something.
Are you ready for your ASMR session? But, but, but.
And you say yes. And I say good.
Okay. I'm growing some ASMR tools.
I'm just picking up my ASMR tools.
Okay. Now this time, are you actually ready for your ASMR session?
Now you say yes.
Mommy, Ashley, can you help yourself? You started it. I'm just ending it.
Okay. Geez, it was your fault. I'm blaming you.
Okay. I'm going to put that in.
And then I'm going to...
quiet. Okay.
Okay. Now I'm going to put that in the middle.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
And then I'm going to bring you closer. Hold on.
I need to check because I'm not strong enough to push it.
I'm not going to lie to you.
There's nothing terrible stuff I'm going to do.
I'm not strong enough for this. Hold on.
I know my nails coming off.
I know I lost a nail from you.
Okay. I lost a nail. Hold on. We lost one.
Let me put it back on.
Okay. I'm strong.
Sit on it. Sit on it.
I mean, yeah, I'm sure. Sorry. I don't want to cast on the shadow.
Let me stand a little to the left like the head video game.
Sorry, my voice is dying.
Okay.
One.
So it's really hard to do.
This is not easy.
Okay.
I already made the audio. I just need to upload it.
I literally made an audio of me sitting on the microphone. Over and over and over and over and over.
How much to be the doll? You are the doll.
Look at me. I even got you a new little nicotine patch.
Please call me a good boy.
You're such a good boy.
Okay.
What's going on?
I mean, what's the deal?
I need my ball. It's not staying.
Stay.
I'm not going to play.
I should be.
I should be. Sorry.
It's dangerous to go alone.
I'm trying to stick this on.
You might take interest in trying to stick it in there.
It wasn't long ago.
Is it unique to be called a good boy written in mummy issues?
No. You are allowed to crave things such as being praised.
Being told that you're genuinely doing a good job.
I think it kind of comes into that.
Sorry to put my tinfoil hat on. I'm literally...
To make it better, I will twerk once I explain.
I think it's perfectly normal
to seek out attention.
Positive reinforcement.
I'm not kidding. I'll start twerking to keep your attention to talk through this book.
I like to use things.
It takes like 40 minutes, but one.
All your praising is just amazing. Thank you.
Literally, it is perfectly natural
to want to be praised and to want to be told
you're doing a good job and that you're literally
doing fantastic. I don't know what the problem is.
It's fine. It's natural.
It's perfect.
You shouldn't be embarrassed about it either because think about it like your childhood.
You're told, oh, good boy. You're so creative. You're doing fantastic.
Keep it up. Check out you. And then boom.
Then boom. What happens?
Nothing. You get absolutely successful. You wonder you crave it.
You literally had this thing for many a year and then all of a sudden you turn a random age
and you don't get it anymore. Of course you're going to crave it. It's perfectly natural.
Was that flossing? No, no. This is flossing.
Hold on. Pause the ASMR. I'm here to do the foot movements.
Oh, shit. How did I do that? Oh, there we go.
Oh, you can't see it. We're going to have to do the fucking crutch.
No, it was that one.
It's all right. Back to your ASMR.
Come here, patient zero.
Come here. Can I push this chair back?
That's the hate one.
Sorry. This chair can go back.
I'm not strong enough. Oh, my God.
Okay, that's going to have to do. Did I even achieve anything?
I didn't. Well, don't face that.
That didn't work. Okay.
Patient zero.
Put the microphone here and pray that it doesn't fall.
Just because it doesn't fall.
Okay.
If I can pull this off, I'll be it.
Hold on. I'm going to go for that.
I need to, like, go on my right.
Okay, I'm going to pull that way for now.
Okay.
I'm going to fix you.
Oh, my God, you can't tingle so hard, right now.
Little bad.
She just sat on us over here.
And she tingled under my blanket.
Mannequin.
I've already played.
Heart drop moment. Wait, what did I do?
Where did you get the mannequin? I taped
in Cairo Practor model.
And it was the best that I could do.
I'm tingling you.
Okay.
My heart drops whenever
some says face and something
is conditioned.
Okay.
My chest.
Oh, my head.
Oh, this is looking good.
She just kidnapped the reef and made him into a model.
Looks like a weird ritual.
It is.
So if you're hearing the brushy brushy brush.
Oh, I wonder if I can do this.
Oh, my God.
Right, is this going to work?
Five hands.
Okay.
This might work.
Are you joking?
Okay.
What do you want me to do?
If you look at you there,
it probably does.
I will put them below.
Is it the wrong ear?
No, it's Shaisa.
I didn't think that far.
This is the wrong ear.
I'm going to do this.
Oops.
Just flip this over.
Or if I do it all at the same time.
Oh, you mean like this?
Wait, is that going to work?
Why am I being dumb?
It's very problematic.
Face down, face up.
No, it's not.
That hurt.
You know what else is going to hurt?
I'm going to sit on your hand.
I'm going to do this.
I think I can do that with my huge tip.
Hold on.
I want to move in his voice so much.
I just dropped the stuff down.
Sorry if you saw that.
Okay.
We're gonna do some ear cleaning.
Her legs are so thick.
I have like the fucking hidden baby faces in my arms.
Okay.
So I have a hand.
You listen to the big daddy audio?
I was trying so hard to talk and we're getting in the wrong way.
I definitely am going to record like an actual video to this year.
And I'll dub in like all the sound effects.
I think that would be quite nice.
Okay.
Can I go to the other side to sort of ruin the leg thing?
I don't know.
Oh no.
This is fine.
This is the most I've ever learned on an ASMR video.
I wish I could teach you more about the body.
But I can't really remember anything else off the top of my head.
Like I didn't research any of that.
That was just knowledge inside me.
The story is so painful.
Can you feel?
I'm like milked.
Or in the wise words is she be caught and boom.
I'm like so we're milked.
I actually hate she be.
I've never forgotten.
That's the fun that's gone.
Do you want to teach your education?
Okay, I can do more education.
I'm awful about viruses, if you know.
I can do it real quickly.
You're not feeling so good.
So this is wrong.
Unfortunately, I only have one of these.
This tingle effect doesn't work.
Oh, I can put like...
Can I put like tape scopes on with snails like this?
Who knows what that sounds like?
Let's tell Reflinge.
You're in the testing...
You're in the ACP testing facility.
This is ACP, so I know.
That's my name.
Everything is supposed to be fine.
The visually is perfect.
Mummy, nurse, will you open it?
Hmm, this nails a bit too much for you.
This is...
Okay.
Will we attempt the latex scopes?
I will attempt them for your upcoming...
I hope you've been eating your tomatoes, Reflinge.
Okay, so this is what's going to happen.
I'm going to go for a P exam, okay?
You will be put into our room,
and you'll be asked to take care of this thing off.
You can keep your shirt on if you really want, okay?
And you'll be asked a few questions, okay?
So the questions are going to be...
How is your P full?
Do you notice that your P...
Sorry, I'm in your P stage, so I'll be facing you.
So you'll be asked, is your P full okay?
Do you have any concerns?
Do you have any discomfort when you're pain?
Have you noticed that you tinkle a little,
even when you have more in your bladder, okay?
And then you'll answer all these questions.
And then the assistant, nurse, will leave the room.
And you'll be asked the strip down.
Just take it off from the bottom down.
So you can keep your socks on.
Maybe not your shoes on the table,
but they'll have a sheet of paper for you.
And then you'll be asked to go in your safe.
And then put your knees up a little bit, okay?
And this is how you determine
if you've been eating enough tomatoes and not refilling, okay?
This is how I'm going to do it when I come and meet you, right?
Take a bit of it, the one you think of.
Try and find it, you need to relax.
Relax, relax, let me in, okay?
And then you'll determine if it's enlarged
or not your truthful answers
and all that jazz would mean that.
And then once you've been a good boy,
that's basically how it goes online.
It's not a yell.
It's not that.
It's not going to hurt.
It shouldn't hurt, okay?
That sounds a little easy.
Yeah, basically that's what I'm going to do.
And then do that.
And then you'll get treatment based on results.
So you can do more experiments, can't you?
I can play with you all night.
Okay.
And I'm going to sit down with you
because I'm getting a little bit talented.
I'm starting up because I'm a tired baby.
Okay, come here, baby.
It's my proof that I'm a sickly chicken pox,
so I need to keep latex poxing.
Oh, hold on.
The back of my chair's not...
That was really loud and unnecessarily loud.
I'm so sorry.
I did not know it was going to make that any noise
when I picture it back up.
Literal gunshots.
Yeah, the back of my chair is now sitting upright again.
That was so loud.
I'm so sorry.
That was the back of my chair.
Please send any grievances to Secret Lab
at your next convenience.
Okay.
Okay, so now you sit.
And I need to wear gloves
because you've got chicken pox,
even though I've had chicken pox before,
so I'll be fine.
But the thighs are pink.
I have terrible news,
but blood is flowing through these thighs.
So-called anarchists,
when I touch their pasta,
oh my goodness.
Are the tomatoes supposed to help with that?
Yes.
So, tomatoes
help with your tushis
a little prostate in there.
But if you're not feeling well,
what am I going to do with it?
I'm going to look after you.
Oops, sorry.
That was really loud.
I'm here for you.
Oh, no.
You've broken both your hands.
Big brother.
I should get Amy to read the Reddit post.
Yes, I will.
I will do something so cursed like that.
I'm pretty sure there's a Reddit post about a-
was that a brother?
He broke his arms or something?
Oh, no.
I think it was with his mum.
Well, we're not doing that.
I'm here for breakfast.
I'm going to hook him.
It was a son.
No.
Okay.
Well, we're going to do a little remix.
Okay?
So-
Oh, no.
Big brother.
I'm not trying to steal-
Oh, wait.
Should I be big sister?
Oh, no.
Little brother.
He broke both your wee arms.
Pretty.
You can't just bring it up and I'll give you the song.
I should have just taken like Reddit broken arms story as ridiculous.
I guess even Reddit-
Can be based once in a while.
Brother with the key.
Yeah, brother with the key.
What manga are we talking about?
Oh, ain't no manga.
Apparently it's a real life story.
I don't know.
Shit.
I mean, do we believe in it now?
All types.
Rubber gloves.
Definitely.
The tear blister thing.
And they're starting my arms are broken.
This pressure of my kind of little deal.
Say no more, chief.
And the script has already been written in my mind.
Help me fall and I can't do that.
So the first, when we find a patient unconscious,
remember your ABCs.
First airways.
Okay, there's nothing obstructing your area.
B, breathing.
Perfect.
C, I always forget what C is.
Conscience?
Cosh?
No, I can't ABC.
I think it's something to do with blood flow for C.
I can't remember.
Circulation.
Oh my God.
Oh God, are you bleeding anywhere?
Where's your blood going?
Refling.
Refling, your blood isn't in your head.
Where is it?
Oh, we need to check your body for it.
So it's not in your head.
It's not in your neck.
Your blood flow isn't in your shoulders.
Or down your arms, in your hands.
Or on your chest, your stomach.
Or your thighs, your calves, your feet.
Refling.
Where's your blood flow?
You need that blood to heal elsewhere.
To keep pinging the people, not keep people.
Nurse drawing the hands are broken.
Oh my prostate is pounding.
You mean pulsing?
What's going on back here?
What's all this movement back here?
It's just a normal biological reaction.
I was reading a Reddit story.
Sorry, I like to bring raw on the Minecraft Reddit stories.
And it was about guys getting Brazilian waxes.
They were called like a manzillion or something like that.
And they were just like, pochoo, pochoo.
And then they always get a, a you-know-what.
And then when they're getting like waxed or whatever.
I don't know.
I didn't know that.
So much blood flowing in person now.
More weight getting flowing.
How do you undo brick when you did?
What's the quickest way to do?
Do you want the medical quickest way to get rid of a hard time?
I can tell you a trick and this is actually used in the medical field in the military.
If you ever were in a situation where now is not the time and you have the privacy.
I kid you not, one flick to the tip, it will be gone.
You will have no problems and it will go straight back to regular schmacular size.
This is a real medical thing that is done, especially in the military during assessments.
One flick to the tip is gone.
You are not going to be tending.
I can assure you that much.
Oh.
How hard should a flick?
Do you see?
You guys are reacting already to the thought of that situation.
Can't be too wrong.
So like a shotgun.
I heard doctors hit it with a cold spoon.
I wish I knew that in high school.
Clench your thighs and arms to force blood flowing in person.
I don't know.
I remember that next time I did it in bloods.
Jeez, how much of a nurse special interest do you have?
Guess she'd be to help.
I think she knows about hidden bits.
How does it?
Oh, okay.
Flights in your muscles can bring it down, by the way, because of blood flow codes to the muscle.
I don't know that.
Pretty much any insurgent forceful impact to the tip drives it into retreat.
I don't, people won't notice you doing that right before a present.
Stop.
You're about to do a presentation for the company and you're in the corner and you quickly sip.
I might just go, and then I might put it back up again.
Holding your breath works as well.
I'm curious.
What did I do if that just makes me...
You're not supposed to enjoy it.
What are the marks on the mannequin?
So this mannequin is actually a chiral-practin.
Don't ask me a thing about chiral-practin.
I don't have a clue, but it's basically like all the systems they say, but...
I don't know what my thoughts are on chiral-practin.
From what I've seen it seems faint and deep.
So the time I hear a story about it, it's like this person died from chiral-practin.
That's a shame.
The lips and I'm like, oh.
There's a really half-dead thing to do there.
I mean, how should I do this?
Actually, I think I've come to, like, acupuncture, yeah.
Oh, that's right, acupuncture, not chiral-practin.
They do the same thing, you know.
In terms of schemizing through people that are just in agony,
because they've got, like, a trap here.
I thought I broke my chair there, and I was about to fall off the tape.
Wait.
How did I have the microphone and the mannequin in the shot at the same time?
I don't know.
Yeah, there's, like, loads of indents to teach you, like, where the pressure points are.
I'll be damned if I'm letting some stick a fucking needle in me like that, mate.
I'll be damned if I fall off.
I'm fake.
Ah, let's go.
You do not approach anyone with a needle.
All right.
Need this thing.
Do you want this?
Yeah.
But yeah, there's, like, a lot of indents.
Can you hear that?
I'm trying to quiet so you can hear the indents.
Something like that.
She's touching my hoof.
I mean, you know.
Yeah, it's hard if I force you to keep coming back, eventually.
Especially if you find out how deep we go in the air until she misses me.
At acupuncture, of course, relaxing.
I will do it for free on you, so you stop going,
because I have heard so many horror stories about acupuncture.
Like...
Sorry, you cannot convince me that piercing the skin,
damaging your body is somehow going to heal me.
Well, actually, you might take that back,
because I'm pretty sure that's what we've been doing, some medical cases.
But you know what?
That's just medical cases.
Let me be ignorant, okay?
I've not done my research on the topic.
Let me have my ignorant opinion about it.
Okay?
Gosh, why does everyone have to be educated just to speak these days?
Why can't I just be dumb and have a terrible, terrible opinion?
Well, some medical cases use that.
How dare you?
How dare you speak the truth?
You know what?
You've frustrated me.
I'm going to sit on you in a minute.
I don't think I'm not sitting on this.
I'm going to come again.
I can do it like doing an arm as well.
Obviously, it's quite low quality.
Get educated.
Don't try and do something good, then.
Strongly dimble, roughly, then.
I mean, right now, because I'm uneducated.
Where's the mark?
Or do you want, like, a voice with that?
What would a valedict or a Scottish person seem like?
Oh, my God.
I had no clue about that.
Oh, you're so smart, Riflin.
How come you care all of this?
I didn't even remember learning any of that in school.
They're such a smartie-pants, honestly.
It's actually really impressive how smart you are.
I wish you could, like, talk to me more, like, tonight.
Like, maybe I come over to your house tonight
and stay in your bed and you just keep yapping in my ear
and telling me everything that's going on in the air.
And, you know, maybe you can teach me a thing or two.
I don't really care what I'm doing.
You know what I mean, Riflin?
Is that what you want?
You want a Bimbo Scottish one, then?
School swag needs to be around right.
One, that's hilarious.
Two, stop that.
Sure, do you like Bionicles?
Her feminine home.
Woman with two clothes, pepper spray.
Yeah, I've been more like Plapping.
Oh, what's Plapping, Riflin?
I'm sorry, darling, you're gonna have to tell me what Plapping is.
Can you, like, show me?
I'm a bit of a visual learner, or, well,
I'm, like, doing something more than writing it down on paper.
I'm the brightest you see,
so add any, like, writing notes down.
So you're just gonna have to tell me.
Instant most, actually.
Do not corrupt the woman.
I'm a tactile learner, yeah.
So, are you gonna show me a good time, Riflin?
Is there a lot of examples in coming?
Truth, looking my tip right now?
Stop, that's fine.
Actually, the paternal and the one who should be the bimbo,
because I can't think of a response.
Oh, what's wrong?
Did I sound lucky?
Look, this came out actually.
I'm trying to make myself sound a bit different than you sound.
I think I've spoken to you enough in the Scottish accent
for you to understand the majority of what I'm saying to you, Riflin.
But it's alright if you don't fully understand.
I don't fully understand a lot of things either.
That's why I'm over here, at your house, right now,
because I wanna learn more, Riflin,
and you're gonna teach me.
No, no.
I locked the door.
You're not getting out until you teach me what I wanna know.
Show me the mail and that and...
Basically.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Now that we're together, whatever.
Shh, just take a few hugs with that.
You'll be okay. Stop resisting.
Shh, no, no.
I'm wearing gloves, so there's no fingerprints left.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, look at you.
Oh, I don't know what to do here.
Now that you're so defensive...
I locked the door. I lied already.
I lied. I didn't wanna play with...
I didn't wanna build bionicles with you.
I thought it was a cat, no, it's Gimlin, so I give myself a name.
I'm gonna give her some attention.
Gim?
Gimlin.
Gimlin, I'm doing ASMR, please.
Have a hissy fit any other day.
I'm doing ASMR.
Gimlin.
Just tell me you want to spoil it without telling me.
One second, refunds. We're gonna get a special gift.
Gimlin, you're fine.
Here you go.
She just walked away from the door.
Gimlin.
Here you go.
Come on.
Show yourself to the refunds. Come on.
Here you go. Look.
Show yourself to the refunds.
Oh, there's my baby.
Come up on the chair.
She's like, where the fuck are you wearing gloves?
Gimlin, come up on the chair.
Oh, there's a refund on the chair.
Wait, come here.
She's so confused right now.
She doesn't know how to do it.
Come up on the chair, darling.
Look, it's a refund.
No? Okay.
Wait, so I'll let you in the room for the first breath.
You literally run camera for two seconds.
Come on, I'm trying to make content.
How are you? Get on the chair.
Where's my baby girl?
Come on, I don't like lifting you up.
Where's my baby? I think it's the gloves.
I don't actually like the gloves.
Wait, you out.
And you bear shop and try to do ASMR for the next 10 minutes.
Do you hear me? 10 minutes.
Do you understand? See me out.
See me out if you understand that I'm doing ASMR for another 10 minutes
and you need to be quiet.
Okay, good girl.
That was me.
It's the gloves.
She doesn't like them.
I was picking her up but she doesn't like them all.
You're torturing her.
Okay, she understands that
there's a 10 minutes.
Right, Gimli.
Now that the door's closed, I have pride to say to do what I need to do.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit. I'm spinning.
I'm not supposed to spin.
Okay.
God, I'm on my finger.
Come on.
I don't know.
Do you like that one?
The Clowns.
Wait, can I do a run and jump Clownslam
or is that a terrible idea?
I mean, all terrible ideas start
with a good idea.
Like a good thing behind it.
I don't know. Maybe I can do a run and jump one.
Oh, I can't really tell because of the...
Do the Clownslam?
I mean, this is probably...
Hold on.
God, my fucking nails came off.
Oh, I glue it one more time.
Just give me one more time.
Breathe.
Okay, hold on. Sorry.
I'm gluing thin here.
Please just stay on for the next 10 minutes.
I'm begging you.
I'm getting like a proper action jump.
Sorry.
Okay.
There's no way that isn't enough glue.
Like, sorry, that finger is running and gluing.
There's no way this isn't going to stay.
I will fucking facilitate this one
if that doesn't stop.
My tie is going on.
Screw your sausage. Easy.
Screw your sausage.
Right, okay.
Now that my nails are on,
I can be very demure.
Thank you, I bought them.
They're mermaid nails.
Where's the ruler? Come on, get the ruler.
I know what the people want.
Here's the nails.
Here's the nails. Here's the ruler.
I mean, if I really wanted to squeeze my fingers down,
I can literally, like, do that.
I'm just alone.
I'm going really smooth.
Alright, one last climb, Sam.
Reeflings.
How do you confess to your sins?
Sorry, ignore the trouble in the background.
And the Hoover, because the Hoover...
Reeflings, how do you
confess to your sins of
inking without my permission?
Hmm? How do you confess?
You plead guilty?
Oh dear.
There's only one punishment
for a guilty man like yourself.
Sorry, I'm standing on paper.
Okay.
Does that just jump on you
or do I run and jump on you?
I haven't really thought this far yet.
Like, because I could, like, literally, like...
What? You know, should I just...
I mean, fuck it, fuck it.
Like, because I can just...
You know.
Sk sk sk sk.
There we go.
I don't really know if I can
do it any other way.
I'm like...
I don't even ask how I managed that.
Can you tell what's happening right now?
I'm going to break this down, though.
Hold on.
Oh, my nail!
I just snapped my nail on for that.
That was the worst that I've ever known.
Hold on.
Let me get my nail.
Okay. Thank you for pleading
guilty and
confessing to your sins.
That's right, get teabagged.
I'm not even gonna do about it.
Nothing. I can't do a single thing.
Right.
Now, I'm gonna bring my nail over.
I can't bring it.
Mommy's an acrobat.
I have really flexible legs.
I wish I could show you that.
I can put them behind my head right now,
but I don't think I want to.
Right, I assume now that
there is to take off the nails.
Cause like...
Sorry.
What's that going to do?
Assume...
where I'm about to climb off.
I'm gonna do a face
stream.
Oh, wow. It really is.
It is to take off the nails.
Oh, that feels very
unnatural.
Oh, gosh, we're gonna be here for ages.
I'll try to take these off.
I'm not quite sure.
Okay.
Out of raw curiosity,
I'm gonna go into the corner of my room.
I'm not sure I could
prove it.
Like, right now.
Wait, what was I gonna do?
I mean, touch my toes and stuff.
I'm like, go further than my toes.
You know, like...
I could do that.
I had to do it reverse.
I'm trying to prove I can put my...
I'm not that smart.
So I can figure it out.
I'm not bringing anything away from this.
Let me take off my nails.
Yeah.
I'm just going to stay here.
I'm just going to go through.
I heard this bro. It's Johnny Stabby.
Yeah, I'm Dairy Arc.
Did you know that you can tell
mommy likes you just by her feet
if she has them by her ears?
Oh, you want me to stab one?
She...
You ain't got to tell me twice.
That's right.
I'll try to take that when you get back.
Absolutely nothing.
Absolutely nothing at all.
Thank you for the
kind of membership.
Okay, can I take this off?
This feels really
horrible to take off.
It actually feels like I'm taking the damn thing off.
For free?
Gimli, I can hear you
at the door.
I don't... oh.
You see that?
It's like glue.
It's so sticky.
Refling.
Not by her ears, yours.
Oh, did I mess it up?
Sorry, I ruined your joke.
I'm sorry, bro.
Thank you.
Don't play.
What is that glue?
Refling.
It's so sticky.
Oh, it's all of my nail as well.
Refling.
Good night, Johnny.
There's glue on the glue nails.
I had to glue them on, but I used the face.
You know what?
You're done.
It was like
dried up
snot
or dried up ink.
Okay, so some of them are coming off.
It's so easy.
I'm de-girlifying myself.
That's it, you're getting tomboyed again.
You're getting tomboy goth unlocked.
You're gonna like it at least.
Do you understand?
Oh!
Oh, that one's really glued on.
Who put that much?
Oh, yeah.
That felt awful.
Tomboy art.
You're always a tomboy.
What was that?
Always was.
Wait, you're tomboy starting?
Wait, you're golf starting?
Always was.
You're very girly at all.
Right?
I swear there's probably going to be a Dornathon reward
which is like strongly wear a dress
because I literally didn't wear a dress.
The last time I wore a dress I was out of fucking freedom.
So...
Sorry, you can't see the action show.
Are you ready?
Oh!
Oh, look at all that.
Reflash.
I didn't realize I was sticking your freaking ankle.
I'm getting
a gorilla-fing mix now.
Always have been.
Do you listen to churches?
Because they're Scottish.
I saw them in person.
I was very, very young.
I got to see churches play.
I went off.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, I start that one hard.
I'm not even kidding, I actually can hurt.
Oh my god, have I been?
The other thing I'll be bending
is this later.
Sorry, that was really left.
Have a bit like a sexy, lingerie
dress.
Not like a girly girl dress.
Well, we're discussing it at the end of this week
what you guys want
because I want to make sure you actually get what you...
Oh!
That was a clear, a clear cut case.
That was an easy one.
Okay, you.
Oh my god, I like...
This is the one that came off, so I ended up using
like a ton of wood to keep it on.
Your ability to not...
You want a girly girl dress?
No, we'll be painting.
Gentile.
Did you notice it?
Kind and French.
Oh wait, gentile.
We're thinking...
Gentile in English.
Kind?
I can't remember.
Snippa.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Oh, it kind of hurts.
Ow.
Oh my god, please. Oh, thank god.
I was like, please don't make me a girl forever.
Look, I've got games to play.
So I was...
I've got vermin tide with the boys next week
and by the boys.
Yes, we're playing vermin tide again.
So I just gave them a lesson today, look.
Thank you, Algea, for the extended membership.
I...
I hear French.
Thank you.
C'est va, j'ai un peu de l'extrne.
Oh, you're best at that.
Fucking look at that amount of like nail glue
that's left over.
I've got one more to go.
I've got to do some work.
Have fun at work.
That's right, I said have fun at work.
Ow, ow, ow.
Ow, ow.
It is over with.
I'm a tomboy once more.
Me and the boys.
This is much more like me.
What is all that going on?
No.
This is me.
Stroney and Emmy collab went very soon to him
and me and Emmy actually have a confirmed collab
together with two other people
that you may be familiar with
or may know, I don't know.
Eh, base.
I managed to convince Emmy to play a game.
Mm, mm, mm, mm.
I'm forcing she to be able to play Halo with me.
Mm.
Oh my god.
Reflins.
Why is it so sticky? Reflin?
You didn't warn me before putting your ink on
as glue. It was going to be this sticky.
This is outrageous amounts of glue.
Reflin.
It's...
How do you even produce that?
It's so sticky.
I don't even know how you're doing that.
I can't get it off.
I just have your ink just sitting on my nail.
It literally looks like
I've been picking my nails.
You're welcome.
Coagulation.
Don't ink shame us.
I'll ink shame you.
As much as I please.
Just kidding.
I love your ink.
Please ink more.
Dr. Funding case, you rip a nail.
No, thank you lord.
Just thumbs up my nails for this thing.
We're going to see.
So is that alcohol wipe?
Wipe.
Sorry, don't wipe.
Is that alcohol wipe?
As soon as this is what's going to remove
the alcohol on top of my fingers.
Right?
Copium.
So strong smelling.
It really is chloroform.
This goes to the ink jar.
Thank you lord.
Just thumbs up.
I want to tell you something.
I'm half desolated.
Did I take...
What? Did I take too much...
Sink?
Oh, zinc.
Have you...
Are any of you unironically taken zinc?
You don't need to...
You don't need to take zinc from me.
I assure you.
Oh my god, it's like two squares.
Sorry, that's so cute.
It's like two little squares together.
I'm easily unironically.
Who me? Never.
Nah, I've got more zinc than a battery.
That is amazing.
Zinc will kill you.
It's a multivitamin.
Vitamins, eh?
Cool gum.
But I'm going to get me...
I'm not an iron sheet.
Just watch in my multivitamin.
No, I don't know how many guys I've taken.
Oh, Flintstone gummies.
Is that what you guys are taking?
I didn't realize how popular Flintstone gummies were.
What does zinc help with?
Producing more ink, apparently.
Whether or not it's true.
It's a whole different...
Well, I mean...
Oh, I just dropped it, but...
I mean...
Uh...
No? Question mark?
That did not do what I thought it was going to do?
Like...
I don't know if you can hear
the amount of glue that's still on.
That's glue.
That's not like... You know how when
a nail is smooth, it's like...
It may not...
Only ink can remove it.
Oh, that looks...
Yeah, I'm kind of looking at that one.
Right, is everyone satisfied?
Or do you need... Do you want anything else?
A paper? Oh!
Maybe that's why they give you this.
I'm just not going to have a nail by the time
I'm done with this, I'm going to be honest.
A cuddle, you want me to cuddle?
Send them down to a noob.
I'm just getting full already.
That's just a nail file.
I mean, a sandpaper, just with less grit.
You know, taking them out of grit.
You want some cuddles? I can give you some cuddles.
Baby, go near my little...
Oh, you get...
Uh...
I'm going to go get something, okay?
And it's a...
I may or may not have almost went
to the hospital yesterday, and I'm going to show you why.
I completely forgot
because I took my medicine.
Give me one minute.
I almost went to the hospital yesterday.
You ready, baby?
Did Gimli come in while I was away?
I didn't close the door.
So...
Sigh...
I almost went
to the hospital yesterday.
Do you want to know why
I almost went to the hospital yesterday?
Because I
went to the hospital yesterday
because I was so sick
and I was so sick.
I was so sick.
I almost went to the hospital yesterday
because I was fighting a shower.
Now, for those of you
who are uninitiated
on what this piercing is,
this piercing
belongs on my chest.
I now no longer
have two chest piercings.
I entered the shower
and my piercing
came out.
However,
I have good news.
It turns out
that the chest is so
willing to heal itself
that
it closed very quickly
the location that was split.
And it is now
back to being a part of me when originally
it wasn't.
So I almost went to the hospital
but I didn't
because it closed up.
I am okay.
I am on pain medication
but unfortunately
this angel has lost
one wing. I still have one wing left
but
I thought maybe it's a funny ha ha
the top
donator can have my wing
if you want it.
So, yeah,
I'm not going to lost too much
because I don't want to give away but
let me just get so
this one should actually be here right now.
This one is not here.
It's in my hand.
It should be right here
but it's not. So I have one
wing on. This angel has one wing.
So that's
the story about how I almost went to the hospital
and it wasn't about my heart.
A Christmas miracle.
So you split your neck I did
on a shower nonetheless.
Oh sorry, did you see my butt?
That's impossible.
I'm now a one winged angel
and no, I'm not getting it redone
before anyone's like, I need a repairs.
No, I'm not getting a repairs. You're done for.
New wing fund, it must feel weird.
No, I'm literally not. I'm too scared.
Nietzsche junkie bird.
Thank you, I'm actually too scared.
Did you try to do a handstand in the shower?
I tried.
So the shower in my rental
it's not like it opens
180 degrees
it can only open 90 degrees
but because the door
was open into the shower
like into the shower room
it was 45 degrees
and I was like, I'm going to be
so skinny Malinky
and put myself in the shower
at a 45 degree like opening
and I caught my
and it came right out.
This is why I need
I need cuddles, okay?
And
I am on painkillers, please don't worry.
I did a ton of research
and basically what happened is
a lot of people said it actually closes
if you hold it and I did the pressure thing
and I'm like, okay.
You want to kiss it better?
Okay, kiss it better.
Excuse me, where my kiss is?
Please kiss it better.
I said kiss it better, right now.
I'm enjoying better
right now.
Kiss it.
Okay, thank you
and I keep getting
to you.
My little baby
and we know it's a refill because you have
your little thing here.
Oh my baby.
To you.
My little baby.
Did you know that saliva is
a healing agent? Is it actually?
After the kiss of someone like
kisses in Scottish?
Aggressively
kisses in.
Okay.
Give us the kids back.
Modes have too much bacteria to risk it.
Yeah, I had that in
Modes like a whole ton of
things.
Great.
I know that always come quiet.
I'm going to see
if she be on and I can redirect
into her and I'll go
risk. Actually, I should be watching
Shrek right now in a membership stream.
I'm so sorry, I got distracted.
Hold on.
Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute.
Is she being up?
Raid.
Yeah, I'm reading Sheepsters.
If the raid function wants to work
because it literally never wants to work.
Customization redirect.
Oh, she's doing ASMR as well.
Well, she'll actually be doing
real ASMR unlike me.
Okay, so these changes were saved.
So we're going to redirect into Shebe
and then for the membership briefings
we are going to watch Shrek and if
you just give me like five minutes to clean up.
Oh, no.
I'm such a liar.
I've completely forgotten.
Hold on.
I've completely forgot to show you this
nature thing. Hold on.
I'm so sorry.
I'm such a fake streamer.
Oh my God, give me one second.
I'm going to show you something real really quickly.
So easier. Thanks for the stream.
ASMR is great in your voice. Oh, thank you.
Hold on.
Hold on. I've got another thing to show you.
Oh, God, that's so lovely.
Can anyone guess what I'm going to show you?
I don't know if you're going to be able to guess that.
Pokemon kind.
Nail.
Full on the other shop. Nice try.
A Lego set? No, that didn't arrive yet.
I did have a Lego set on the leasing.
Judging by the same drug?
No, gamer's thoughts?
No, my PR package did arrive though.
I need to ask for permission.
Oh, you got it.
Veil or key chain.
No, my proper color isn't here.
Ah, I took my nails off.
This would have been so much better if I could...
Here's Marys V.
Shoulda picked Marys V.
And then I've got Sheeby.
They're so cute.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to do an ASMR video.
Like, tapping.
Just pure tapping on these.
That'll be the video. I could do nothing.
I'm going to take nails back on.
And then I've got
myself.
And Azura.
Oh, my good son.
Shoulda picked me.
Sorry, I'm biased for moments.
I'm biased for me.
Oh, my God. I look so cute.
What the fuck?
Matt, Sheeby's are so cute.
Because my design is so, like, cheap-a-fall.
Cheap-a-fall. Cheap-a-fiable.
And, of course, I've got Azura.
You're Mum-meh.
So you've got Mummy and Mum-meh.
This is Mum-meh.
If you want to focus a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Now, last but not least, we've got the twins.
And before you ask, wait, why are they called twins?
In development,
I refer to
them as the twins.
Because they were both a lollipop.
So these are my twins.
My babies.
Oh, the embers.
Oh, the ace.
But yeah, these are on UwU Market.
If you want just a little casual keychain.
To show, to silently show your support.
Because, literally, I don't think anyone's going to look at you funny
for having an anime girl.
Let's be honest, anime is the most
fucking popular medium right now.
But I am going to record
an ace and more video.
I'm going to put the fake nails back on.
Oh, yeah, it is mine.
You know?
I'll take your entire sotsies.
You can...
I'm very happy to say
that if you buy anything off of UwU Market,
all the profits go to the girls.
Veal or I do not take a cut.
So, if you buy stuff for AC,
you're supporting AC, you know what I mean?
You buy stuff from Emmy,
you're supporting Emmy.
And it's the same for all the girls, we all have the same deal.
I made sure of it.
I was not getting...
What is it, the height of that nail?
I'm just going to pump it.
Yeah, I was...
No, I haven't. No one's getting a scum almost.
A little mercy.
We'll see.
Yeah, if you want to support any of the girls, you can.
But if you want a keychain,
these are probably the most silent support you can do.
Just because it's really...
It does not get in the way.
If this is on a keychain with tons of other stuff,
Gimli...
Gimli, do you want to shovel the girls with me?
Be honest.
What about the designer?
The designer was from Ubu Market.
He did it in house.
I got the concept art means.
But the designer gets paid a fee
by Ubu Market for the publishing rates.
And then I want to see Gimli.
You want to see her again?
Oops, sorry, just bumped the camera.
You want to say goodbye to the refunds?
No, as soon as I open the door,
she walks away. She's actually such a cheeky.
In you go.
Are you going to watch Rick with me in the refunds?
Come here.
Come here, baby girl.
There you go.
She does not.
Oh my god, you're freezing.
Don't you put the heat in on?
Sorry, I'm going to go put the heat in on for her.
Right, I'm going to redirect into Sheevee.
Thank you so much for the ASMR stream.
That's never an ASMR stream, let's be honest with me.
I will see you goofy gubbers later.
Thank you Ting, Spiny.
Well mate, it just occurred to me that Asi could actually be in his twin.
Maybe she was on a flight when her twin wasn't
and they separated her.
Oh no.
Is that Vigo? Did you just come in as well?
Okay, they're both in the room.
Right, you guys win.
You guys win, you're finally allowed in on stream.
But thank you so, so much.
My hair.
Please enjoy Sheevee to your heart's content.
I apologize that whenever I do ASMR,
I don't actually do ASMR.
I know what I saw, please.
For those of you who are a member,
we are going to watch Reckon in about 10 minutes.
You just need to give me a hot second
and then I will be able to
rate Vigo.
I get it.
Okay, love you. Talk to you later, Reefland.
Okay, I'll see you in a minute.
Bye.
Please redirect.